IT DOESN’T HAPPEN.
THANK YOU AS ALWAYS.
THIS JUST BREAKING RIGHT NOW,
BREAKING NEWS FROM FOXNews.com
AND BROOKS DIGNAN, SHE IS
REPORTING WITH A LAPTOP IS IN
FACT LINKED TO AN FBI LAUNDERING
PRO.
THE FBI ALLEGEDLY SUBPOENAED THE
LAPTOP AND THE HARD DRIVE AND
2019.
THEY’VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS 2019,
WHICH IS A WHOLE SERIES OF
ISSUES.
ACCORDING TO THIS REPORT, IT IS
UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT WHETHER
THIS INVESTIGATION IS ONGOING
AND IF IT WAS DIRECTLY RELATED
TO BIDEN.
MULTIPLE WILL FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS HAVE
NO CONFIRMED THE AUTHENTICITY OF
THESE DOCUMENTS WHICH WERE
SIGNED BY FBI SPECIAL AGENT
JOSHUA WILSON WHO DID NOT
IMMEDIATELY RESPOND.
WE WILL STAY ON THE STORY, WE’RE